das heißt die Grünen haben uns 50
Milliarden getötet weil ja am Ende das
fing doch an mit wir haben keinen Strom
Problem dann hörten wir streckbetrieb
geht nicht funktioniert nicht bringt
nichts dann wurde gesagt zwei
Kernkraftwerke und dann im
niedersächsischen Wahlkampf wurde wurden
die Bürger hinter die Fichte geführt das
hat dann ja auch geklappt und jetzt ist
auf einmal alles wieder gut und am Ende
muss man feststellen 50 Milliarden
weniger in den Taschen der Bürger und
der Unternehmen und das kostet
Arbeitsplätze am Ende es kostet unsere
Arbeitsplätze weil wir konkurrieren ja
mit Strompreisen in Amerika von 2 Euro
Cent und in China von 3 Euro sind und
deswegen muss man jetzt schon sagen
diese allgemeine Zufriedenheit die sich
da jetzt so breit macht
da muss man auch ein bisschen verwarnen
denn
das reicht hinten und vorne nicht